- [Narrator] If you go to
Mexico City, in the neighborhood
Merced La Buena, in the
intersection of San Nicolas
and Oriente, through this rusty iron door,
and up two flights of stairs,
you will meet the family
that changed Mexican folk art forever.
(crickets chirping)
Uh (clears throat), sorry, I
didn't mean to disturb you.
(triumphant orchestra music)
- (in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Alebrijes,
the fantastical creatures
traditionally made out of papier-mâché.
Across Mexico, you can find
these beautiful monsters everywhere.
You can find them in the
streets, in the museums,
there are workshops of alebrijes scattered
around the city.
And there's even a huge
parade of monumental alebrijes
that takes over Mexico City once a year.
Ah, and you can catch them in Coco.
- Are those...
Alebrijes!
- [Narrator] But what
exactly is an alebrijes?
- [Leonardo] (in foreign language)
(fire crackles)
(in foreign language)
- [Narrator] And all
of this vast tradition
can be traced back to
one man, Pedro Linares,
Leonardo's grandpa, who said that after
falling into a coma, had a
nightmare where some very dark
and horrific creatures kept screaming
the word, "alebrije" to him.
- [Creatures] "Alebrijes,
alebrijes" (whispers sinisterly).
(sinister laugh)
- [Narrator] Not long after waking up,
he started building the first alebrijes.
(light flute music)
And now his son and grandchildren
continue the tradition.
- (in foreign language)
(soft music)